well there are ominous new signs that
the u.s is on the verge of yet another
strong wave of the coronavirus
on friday more than 57 thousand new
cases were reported
there are now more than 7.6 million
known infections across the country and
the death toll has climbed to more than
213
thousand michael george is here in new
york with our report michael
good morning michelle good morning
preventative measures are already in
place across the country
here in new york city broadway will
remain shut down
through may by then these theaters will
have been closed for more than a year
a surge in coronavirus cases coming
during flu season
has health professionals preparing and
warning for the worst
we do see some of those early signs that
we saw
across the south after memorial day a
sense that there's early
asymptomatic silent spread dr debra
burks of the white house coronavirus
task force
toured the northeast this week warning
of a surge
and pointing the finger at those
responsible it's happening
in homes and social occasions and people
gathering
and taking their mask off stepping up to
help
these volunteers in new york are
literally standing on street corners
handing out
masks i've been seeing a lot of people
without masks
so they see us and they're grabbing it
but also in new york city members of the
orthodox jewish community took to the
streets
and took the governor to court for
closing houses of worship in order to
slow the spread
a federal judge sided with the governor
friday
well look we are going to go through a
tough few weeks here in new york city
while new york's mayor condemned the
protests the state is
tightening restrictions in places where
the virus is spreading
and it's impacting broadway it certainly
is possible
that many shows will not be able to come
back
the broadway league says shows are a 15
billion dollar a year boost to the local
economy
now some 97 thousand workers are waiting
in the wings
including oboist keeve wilson she's part
of the musical ensemble of the show
company i feel like we're in a holding
pattern but we do have to make some
choices
i talked to a musician yesterday who
said she's going back to school for
accounting
to try to have a new career
and of course the broadway shutdown is
more than just a hit to the economy
it's a symbol of this city the shutdown
means that new york city won't be
fully back to normal for at least
another eight months jeff
michael thank you